nos fautes bonjour député du Haut-Rhin
porte-parole du MoDem vous êtes le
délégué général de l'Assemblée
parlementaire de la Francophonie vous
connaissez très bien le sel vous étiez
au Niger il y a quelques semaines encore
il y avait urgence à évacuer les
ressortissants français effectivement
dans une situation qui est instable on
sait pas très bien on va et dans une
situation dans laquelle il y a un
ultimatum de la CEDEAO dans 5 jours pour
que
l'organisation institutionnelle soit
rétablie et que le présent Bashung soit
rétabli dans dans ses fonctions par les
par les puces donc oui bien sûr dans ce
contexte là il faut imaginer et préparer
tous les scénarios et celui-ci est un
des éléments de du scénario qui du pire
c'est-à-dire une intervention militaire
est-ce que vous croyez à alors
effectivement c'est ce que la CEDEAO a
menacé de faire dimanche on va y revenir
à la prix plusieurs sanctions contre la
junte et menacer six d'ici une semaine
l'ordre constitutionnel c'est-à-dire le
président Bazoom n'était pas remis dans
ses fonctions
intervenir militairement au Niger elle
l'a déjà fait par le passé est-ce que
vous pensez cette menace crédible c'est
un des scénarios mais c'est le scénario
ultime mais il y a des étapes avant et
donne très nombreuses possibilités de
résoudre cette situation autrement
notamment par la discussion par la
négociation donc il y a eu la tentative
de président du Tchad de venir il y a
pas eu grand chose à l'arrivée mais
aujourd'hui
en plus donc c'était un peu compliqué
comme comme schéma mais pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des discussions importantes
entre la jante et puis certains nombres
d'acteurs à Niamey et
c'est que la jungle en tout cas n'est
pas complètement n'a pas un front
unanime il y a des gens qui disent à
entendre en tout cas certains membres de
l'agence oui préférerait sortir du jeu
avec une impunité à négocier que de
continuer dans une voie dans laquelle
effectivement
pas beaucoup d'alternatives pour pour
les puces donc il y a des rapports de
force et je pense l'opération de
l'évacuation fait partie justement des
éléments qui procèdent justement à au
rapport de force pour amener les
puccistes à négocier et à la reddition
on voit derrière vous Bruno fucks les
images de l'ambassade de France tournée
dimanche qui a été l'objet de très forte
pression tension dégradation est-ce que
le risque de rupture entre le Niger et
la France aujourd'hui réel ça dépend
quel Niger si c'est les puces oui bien
sûr puisqu'on voit qu'ils utilisent ils
ont laissé faire clairement je sais que
les manifestants avaient été arrêtés
dans le premier barrière avant
l'ambassade et puis un moment il les a
ils les ont laissés passer donc tout ça
est assez téléguidé on est quand même il
faut garder les deux niveaux il faut
regarder la réalité des enjeux
politiques et puis toutes les actions de
communication qui vit justement à créer
des rapports de force on l'avait vu au
Burkina le fait d'avoir attaqué
directement la France en tout cas un
criminer la France dans dans ce qui
était de fausses informations sur le
rôle de la France lors du coup au
Burkina avait amené une partie de la
population à rallier les puces donc on
voit que ces opérations de communication
ont un rôle sur l'évolution de des
situations donc là sur l'ambassade
typiquement c'était une opération qui
avait été diligenté qui a été manipulé
en tout cas pour créer une pression
forte sur la France sur la communauté
internationale dites-vous mais bien sûr
pourquoi par qui on voit bien par par
des intérêts qui visent justement à
quand vous avez fait un coup d'État qui
rien de légitime qui est un coup d'État
dans lequel on voit bien que une partie
des puccistes le font entre guillemets
pour convenance personnelle c'est-à-dire
pour des raisons de stratégie
professionnelle on les affecte à une
tâche qui leur paraît pas suffisamment
intéressantes du coup si on laisse
prospérer ce genre de pratique on est
dans un désordre international permanent
et donc ce qui se joue là au-delà de la
relation entre la France et le Niger
c'est
quel type de société on veut qu'elle
ordre quel type de d'ordre international
on veut est-ce que l'on peut à tout
moment avec quelques militaires faire un
coup d'état pour des raisons
personnelles ou est-ce que on garantit
un moment les institutions telles que
les Niger c'est doté et donc les enjeux
pour la communauté internationale est un
jeu de type de société dans lequel on
veut vivre est-ce qu'on veut une société
démocratique d'expression publique de
liberté publique et des tas de droits ou
est-ce que à tout moment un ou deux
pucciste ou militaire peuvent prendre le
pouvoir par la force de façon
complètement illégitime et donc ce qui
se joue au Niger est bien plus important
que la situation nigérienne c'est le
type de société en Afrique qui peut
générer ou être issu de la situation
telle qu'elle va être résolue au Niger
vous l'avez évoqué il y a évidemment un
des précédents récents et au Burkina et
au Mali
ces deux gens t'ont apporté d'air c'est
assez rare dans un Community conjoint
ces dernières heures leur soutien à la
jointe nigérienne et se faisant l'écho
des menaces de la CEDEAO qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure d'intervenir
militairement si l'ordre ne revenait pas
il y a dit
ivoire une menace de déclaration de
guerre on va écouter l'un des
porte-paroles de la gente malienne on en
reparle juste après
le gouvernement de transition du Burkina
Faso et du Mali 1
exprime leur solidarité fraternelle et
celle des peuples burkinabè et maliens
au peuple frères du Niger qui a décidé
en toute responsabilité de prendre son
destin en main et d'assumer devant
l'histoire la plénitude de s'assouvrir
un été toute intervention militaire
contre le Niger
s'assimulerait à une déclaration de
guerre contre le Burkina Faso et le Mali
tout intervention en hiver
s'assimilerait à une déclaration de
guerre contre le Burkina et le Mali
est-ce que vous croyez une espèce de
front humide uni pardon des gens des
jantes West Afric politique bien
évidemment contre l'Occident et les
organisations internationales mais de là
à ce que les armées maliennes au
burkinabé qui ont du mal déjà assurer
l'intégrité de leur territoire
interviennent réellement il y a un pas
donc là on est vraiment dans l'échéance
la fixer la CEDEAO avec des positions
des uns et des autres pour arriver je
l'espère à une résolution de la
situation avant l'échéance ou juste
après les chances avant même qu'une
opération armée puisse être engagée pour
revenir à la question de la France il y
a un enjeu économique on parlait de
l'uranium quoique le Niger on le disait
n'est pas non plus le partenaire le plus
important de la France aujourd'hui sur
cette d'Auré il y a un enjeu militaire
on rappelle qu'il y a 1500 soldats
français aujourd'hui au Niger rapatriés
précisément du Mali qu'est-ce qu'il peut
leur arriver mais on a aussi
la question elle est pas
franco-nigérienne elle est
internationale vous avez 800 forces
américaines vous avez des Allemands vous
avez des Italiens vous avez des
gendarmes roumains espagnols belges etc
donc on voit toute la communauté
internationale qui est au Niger et donc
c'est pour ça que la situation n'est pas
franco-nigène bien sûr les Français sont
formés et puis en France on voit la
situation de cette façon là mais elle
est beaucoup plus largement
international et elle concerne avant
tout les pays africains est-ce que
Sénégal la Côte d'Ivoire le Bénin vont
accepter que une jungle puisse
s'installer comme ça en quelques heures
sans raison politique majeure ce qui
n'était pas le cas en Guinée par exemple
où il y avait vraiment un problème
institutionnel en Guinée avant le coup
d'État donc on peut voir chaque État ne
se ressemblent pas et celui-ci n'est
absolument aucune légitimité donc aucun
pays de la zone et de la communauté
internationale ne peut accepter la
situation au Niger donc il faut dépasser
la relation purement franco-nigérienne
même si aujourd'hui on le voit il faut
assurer la sécurité de nos
ressortissants et que l'opération va
commencer voilà on rappelle
effectivement l'information du début du
journal l'opération d'évacuation de 1500
français qui va commencer dans les
heures qui viennent à depuis Niamey
depuis l'aéroport de Niamey c'est ce que
nous confirmé Cyril Payen tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup Bruno Fox d'avoir répondu
à nos questions